no one wants to bring in the
Palestinians the reason that none of
these countries are taking in
Palestinians don't like uh the Jews is
because they all hate everything let's
go through country by country cuz you
only hear about Israel hey Egypt okay
Egypt they're right there you got Israel
you got Egypt they could take them in
let's go to
Syria hey certainly they'll take in the
Palestinians it's only the Jews who
won't well they kind of say the same
thing as Jordan they say that the
Palestinians should stay and build their
own state and not flee let's go to
Lebanon knock knock Hamas we're not here
are you here no I heard you say there no
one there but that I heard someone say
which means there's someone there you're
so stupid let's go to Qatar the real
reason they've been silent Qatar uh is
because they too hate them in Iran Iran
hates the Palestinians Saudi Arabia yeah
in Saudi Arabia anyone showing any kind
of support for uh the Palestinian cause
can be imprisoned or or worse